One person did
make a brief
statement before getting on the plane,
which he's on now.
I just want to play you what he said.
Well, thank you very much.
This is a very sad day for America.
And it was also very sad driving through
Washington, D.C.,
and seeing the filth and the decay
and all of the broken buildings and walls
and the graffiti.
This is not the place that I left.
It's a very sad thing to see it.
When you look at what's happening,
this is a persecuted person
of a political opponent.
This was never supposed
to happen in America.
This is the persecution of the person
that's leading by very,
very substantial numbers
in the Republican primary
and leading Biden by a lot.
So if you can't beat him,
you persecute him or you prosecute him.
We can't let this happen. In America.
Thank you very much.
Elect you want this trial.
We should point out the
when the former president left office
and left Washington, D.C.,
the city was on lockdown
because of the attack on January six.
That is the city he left behind.
Yeah, well,
we've heard this from Donald Trump
every single time.
You just use the phrase persecution.
He continues to and will continue
to attack
the prosecutors
law enforcement, the judge
and anyone else
who may hold him accountable.
I think it's our job to call it out
every time.
First of all, for being irresponsible,
reckless and potentially dangerous.
We've seen Adam knows firsthand
that people listen to these words, act
on these words.
Ultimately, though,
there will be accountability.
And again,
one of the things
about our criminal justice system,
there's a resolution.
There's not many arenas, professions
in this world
where at the end somebody says,
you win, you lose this.
We will have a verdict.
We heard
we heard the acting former
acting solicitor general
and President Obama and Neal Katyal
saying
he believes this will go to trial
before the election
and will resolve itself
before the election.
I don't know about that.
I mean, Donald Trump's team has estimated
the trial will take nine months.
That's high.
However, I've tried cases nowhere near
this level of importance
or scope that took four or five months.
So let's cut that in half,
let's say for months, five months.
I don't know where there's a four
or five month gap.
Let me say differently.
There is not a four or five month
open gap on the calendar
given the way things stand right now.
Manhattan,
the hush money case
that has March and April,
right after that, the Mar
a Lago case has made
that will take into June and July.
There's not a four or five month gap
to realistically try
this case on either side.
However, those trial dates can move.
Trial dates move all the time.
Jack Smith could certainly prioritize
which of his cases
he wants to put first
and ultimately up to.
What do you think about the timeline?
Yeah,
I think the judges are going to talk.
I think it's common for judges
to talk and work out schedules.
And it certainly seems
like the New York case,
Alvin Bragg,
would be something
that they would put on. Hold it.
Again, it's up to the judges,
but a judge
machine is a reasonable judge.
And I'm sure
if Judge Chuck Ken asked Judge Mershon
to allow
their case
to go for as I'm sure
Judge Mershon would, would
absolutely do that
and allow that to occur.
So we'll see what happens on August 28th
when they set a timeline
then to set a trial date.
And they'll also set
dates for motion practice,
which means
you have to have all of your defenses
and the things you want me to look at,
you know,
the sufficiency of the grand jury
the First Amendment, the venue,
all of the things that the
the advice of counsel
to all the things
that they're going to argue
about this indictment.
The judge will give
Donald Trump's lawyers a deadline
to have to submit those written motions
and then they'll give the prosecution
a deadline to submit those motions.
And then a deadline
to respond to the motions.
And then we'll set a hearing date.
And and that will all happen
probably between September,
October and November.
But by December,
I think
there's no reason
this case can't go to trial
around the first of the year.
And like
like somebody else is saying before,
there's no
procedural issues involved
with classified documents
the way there are in the Mar
a Lago case
with top secret
clearance and and all of that.
So I think that Jack Smith will
turn all the discovery over.
They'll highlight for them
this is where,
you know,
this is we have this much evidence,
but these are the important parts.
Look here and we're ready to go.
It seems like Jack Smith's team
is ready to
hand over an
awful lot of evidence and documents
that they have to the defense.
Yeah. Again,
in the Mar a Lago case,
a lot of those documents
haven't been turned over
because they're they're classified.
And so until the lawyers
get top secret
security clearance
and that's a whole application
and interview process,
they can't even turn over
some of the discovery in the Mar
a Lago case.
This case doesn't have those issues.
So everything can be turned over
right away.
And the attorneys have plenty of time
to prepare between now and whatever,
whatever date they set.
I would suspect it's early next year,
maybe January, February.
How does one estimate
how long a trial
once it begins to actually will last?
There's no science to it.
You ask both sides.
I think the judge will ask both sides
how long to putting
your case, prosecution, defense,
how long do you think
it will take to put in your case?
But judges have a lot of say over
this, too.
I mean,
I've seen judges who have determined
we're going to get this thing tried.
I know everyone wants all the time
in the world.
We're going to get this thing
tried in two months, in three months.
So it's a Push-Pull
between the defense and the prosecution.
And the judge, though,
ultimately does have some influence.
A lot of influence over that as well.
Look,
this is going to be so crucial
when it comes to the issue of timing.
I mean, do
we get a verdict before an election?
And, you know,
will that change anything politically?
You all are the political experts.
I don't know.
Will a guilty verdict change anything?
Certainly.
I agree
that a not guilty verdict or a hung jury
will change things quite a bit.
But assuming that Tim Trump will,
just based on
what we're hearing, is going to utilize
every delay tactic
they have from venue change and so on.
What would is
are you able to make any kind
of an estimation of how long
this could end up going?
All I know is this is just bizarre.
I mean, like
we're talking about an election year
where we can't talk about election stuff.
The credit of
the country has been downgraded,
can't talk about that.
The country is on fire,
weird weather, can't talk about that.
UFOs can't talk about that.
There's 300
Lilliputians running against Trump
in this primary.
None of them are on the air today
talking about anything they care about
because this strategy is working
like a like
Trump is the only person
getting any action even
in a year like this.